secret talents in köln und ihr beiden
habe gewonnen elefant slackliner aus
kaub bei stuttgart josua hier direkt
neben mir und benny
was ist euch vorgegangen als sich das in
sekundenbruchteilen herauskristallisiert
ich fand mich ziemlich seltsam und
ehrlich sagen ich habe darauf gewartet
ja weil kleines licht aus dass ich gar
nicht einmal das licht an und wir
mussten sehr wenig wasser machen sollten
waren nie ganz papier sind wir nicht
gewohnt auf jeden fall bis 1 grad habt
ihr schon mal was gewonnen
noch nicht
der erste wettbewerb richtig abgesahnt
haben ein bisschen
lustige erfahrung und neue erfahrungen
zu uns es gibt ja 10.000 euro habe der
in irgendeiner weise vorher jetzt schon
mal überlegt was er damit macht weil ihr
macht ja was das ist ja jetzt nicht
eigentlich das geht nicht darum dass
ihre videos macht und das geht ja darum
dass er slackliner seien übrigens immer
zur erklärung was das ist also gucken
natürlich auf ihrem kanal blenden bei
unten ein und verlinken es auch
ja man kann es nicht sein tanz nennen es
ist eine rennsport ist sowas wie
skateboarding oder man geht einfach raus
hat spaß und seinen freunden wo wir
tricks aus schaut was in youtube oder
sonst irgendwo andere slackliner machen
und dann versucht es einfach
nachzumachen oder selbst kreativ zu sein
und neue kombination zu werfen wenn ich
erkläre mal bitte was das ist
allein das ist einfach ein ziemlich
cooler sport da spannt man eine art
spannende und bisschen entspannen wird
also speziell sowieso einen rambo
effekte man herauskriegt wenn spannt man
zwischen zwei bäume im park darauf zu
balancieren
ein bisschen kann dem laufenden so dann
machte tricks drauf drehungen die zahl
der überzahl tor fallen lassen euro
fallen lassen da kann alles miteinander
kombinieren ich habe so richtig cool
kann alles kombinieren damit darum geht
es eigentlich das macht nicht nur
schwierige tricks machst du dann die
kombiniert also das habe ich ja schon
oft
und wie seid ihr darauf gestoßen also
wir haben es bei einem jugendevent
kennen gelernt und haben also manchmal
mehr ausprobiert und irgendwann wollte
noch mehr haben slack fieber gepackt und
sind ja quasi so ein bisschen süchtig
würde auch die lage irgendwie drauf oder
irgendwie kennt ist sie dann so ein
bisschen versuchen zu surfen und so und
ist eine lustige sache dann wie viele
stunden macht er das in der woche
also in der woche stunden in der woche
oder schwierig zu sagen jetzt schon
unterschiedlich also ich denke mal vor
einem jahr von einem jahr haben wir das
noch nicht so oft gemacht wird man
einmal einmal die woche ist lecken
gegangen oder so aber jetzt dann seitdem
wir gesponsert werden von allen
slackline und da haben uns ein bisschen
also viermal die woche schon drin also
manchmal mehr manchmal weniger je
nachdem wie man findet aber so genau
also und es kommt dann vielleicht so
auch das 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
15 stunden die woche vielleicht
slackline wie kam so die initiale ihr
habt das kennen gelernt aber wir hätten
ja auch was anderes machen können oder
keine ahnung die zahlreichen
freizeitangebote den korb nutzen können
wie kommt man auf slacklinen im korb bei
stuttgart
wir hatten bock drauf habe den ehrgeiz
entwickelt da ist eine und meinung zu
machen und nach richtig getroffen laufen
zu können oder hat sehen die zu tricks
début bei uns dass ich so auf den
hintern gefallen lassen kommen wir auch
mal haben wir ewig gebraucht im ssb und
zu daneben gefallen und weiß nicht was
irgendwann könnte mir das immer mehr
spaß gemacht jetzt die ganzen tricks zu
kombinieren ist natürlich ein was das
beste und das man am meisten spaß jetzt
fällt mir gerade einmal eine frage
eigentlich nach dem was macht er mit dem
geld habe da gar nicht beantwortet sie
habt ihr ganz geschickt umschifft
ja okay also
geld wir werden auf jeden fall
genau also wir wollen uns vielleicht
also verteilen zutritt auf also unsere
schneider und karl hat ziemlich viel für
uns gemacht das weiß man noch nicht
bereit sind viel da kamen die bäume her
und sagen ja videos schneiden macht das
war kurz gerade noch so viel zu tun mit
der schule und so war dann nachts wissen
wäre da noch beim media schneiden und
den weil man dann auch noch ein drittel
abgeben der tiger genau kalkulieren und
sportgeräte kaufen er will sich ein
einrad und ski kaufen genau und ich habe
mit dem einrad und mit ihren über die
spannende ein anderer menschen gemacht
wir haben auf dem kanal haben ein video
da ist auch zu sehen sind aber was ich
mir noch gedacht haben ich bin ziemlich
cool dass wir
also werden gesponsert von allen
slacklines und so etwa erwähntes ist
bereits wie ist das noch mal
genau und
wir haben da so einen teamleiter und der
organisiert ist alles in so ein dem
könnten damit auch ein bisschen geld
geben dass du da kann das ja da kann es
gut verwerten also da kann sie neue
sachen einfallen lassen beispiel für
neue slackline gestellt zum beispiel
weil ich wollte auch nicht ihrem sponsor
geld geben macht es nicht geht nicht und
er hat genug er hat genug geld lieber
party
ich würde heute schreibt in den
kommentaren was sie machen sollen ihre
leser schön und ihr wisst ihr was er
schreiben soll ich will genau noch eine
organisation unterstützen ich weiß nicht
was also in die richtung weiß ich ich
würde gerne eine organisation
unterstützen die war es gegen sex
sklaven machen weil das mir am herzen
liegt weil das ich habe erstmal spiel
und film gesehen wo es eben um das thema
geht und ja ich nehme mir voll zu herzen
ich hab ich gemerkt da könnt ihr euch
das machen also da
das schlimme situation was der
herrschende viele leute da ehrlich
versklavt werden und zum sex gezwungen
werden und das will ich unterstützen
super dass der sensationellen mein gott
was ist ein korb für jungs gibt ja leute
nehmt euch ein beispiel
sehr gut ich habe gar keine frage
gestellt hat gesagt das ist so geht es
wunderbar also jetzt schon jetzt auch
richtige interview profis tipps habt
jetzt gegeben eine 28 30
also so insgesamt sowie ein ganzes
segment allen zeugen des
aber ihr könnt es schon begreifen was da
passiert ist ja auch ein bisschen ist
also eine nicht richtig also ich bin
immer noch soll man
auf jeden fall
weiß sie noch in einem jahr
martin fischer der letztjährige gewinner
der hat das ja nur eine ausbildung
gesteckt demnach mit würdet ihr in einem
jahr profi slackliner sein und neben
lebensunterhalt damit bestreiten können
aber das steht bei euch jetzt nicht an
sohn von daher wird das sehr spannend
sein was euch in einem jahr wird weil
vor dem nächsten secret talents award
denke ich werde ich euch interview seite
dazu bereiten wir machen
also dann das ausführliche interview und
die heißt jetzt alle fans lag leider
genau wie euer sponsor ja genau also
zufall wir haben gedacht das gibts dafür
nahmen die es noch nicht gibt also bei
youtube mann der uns die firma die
emotion eigenen youtube-kanal erlebnis
lag lions glaube ich und oder elfen
slackline und wir haben alle gedacht er
kommt wir machen noch einen weil es hier
jetzt langsam ins rollen kamen so und in
neue videos gemacht haben immer helfen
slackliner haben beim chef nachgefragt
er fand's cool und unterstützt uns
wissen die macher mit so war okay also
in diesem sinne nächstes jahr dann das
ausführliche interview mit fragen leute
und allem pipapo mit elfen slackliner
und bis dahin sind wir extrem gespannt
genau das letzte interview wie ist das
letzte geräusche in einem klick zum
interview hast es gerade gemacht
genau dann bush